hello are there any questions okay just
keep in mind the whole point of this
talk is to teach you something you might
not have seen before my goal is to make
it easy for you maybe you won't get all
the way but I hope to inspire you so you
can go and look elsewhere if you want to
get further and you've got a problem
which is I'm very smart so I don't know
what you don't know right I I think it's
all easy but you might think otherwise
so please if I say something you don't
understand it's your job to ask me a
question do it by waving your hand or
I'll try to look at slide Oh
occasionally okay
yes it's that good any questions no okay
here's my theme oh no I need this thingy
here's my theme when a mathematical
reasoning can be had it is great a folly
to make use of any other as to group for
a thing in the dark when you have a
candle standing by you and that was said
by John our birth nut in the laws of
chance written a little while ago so how
many of you know little math good how
many of you like math it's your friend
how many of you think math is very scary
it's written in italic letters like
quite a few of you so for those of you
who feel scared of math that's the main
thing I'm here to tell you
math is your friend math is illuminating
if you can use math to do something you
should because it will help you out it
will make things easier right I often
hear from people especially in this
community that's scared of math and so
they come up with reasons like well I
never liked candles in high school I got
burned by one
right but even if you got burned in high
school right that was we had a beautiful
lecture by Eugenio Chang at ICF P I
encourage you to look at it when it's
put up on the web and she said no if you
don't understand something it's not your
fault it's your teachers fault
if you didn't like math in high school
it was your high school that failed not
you so don't worry about it
if you if you find that hard that's okay
but just get stuck in and you will find
things get easier that's what I'm trying
to tell you so I'm going to talk about
something specific called category
theory why on earth am i talking about
category theory so three years ago I
think it was I gave a talk on this stage
on propositions as types my most viewed
talk ever and that's about this great
idea
I will free up my hand and the great
idea is that there two things that are
the same thing
so one of these things is logic which
goes back to the ancient Greeks but
really saw bloom in the 1800s and then
the 1900s and was put down in the form
that I really like by Gerhard Jensen in
1935 he was a Nazi but let's ignore that
so logic was putting this beautiful form
against it in 1935 meanwhile programming
languages get their first definition in
the form of lambda calculus by Alonzo
Church in 1932 well turned out that
system had a logical inconsistency you
could literally prove false in it a bad
idea for such a system so he came up
with a type system which was consistent
in 1940 and it turns out in 1969
Roger Hindley writes up not hindley the
other one curry Howard Robert Howard
Howard writes a paper pointing out that
this thing and this thing are the same
thing right and and what you see they're
the same thing it's completely obvious
but it took 30 or 40 years to see that
this is the great thing in math right it
lets you see something obvious after
just 30 or 40 years that's why you want
maths so they're these two things
they're the same and last time I talked
somebody asked a question
well what about categories so categories
are actually the third thing that is the
same and categories in part model these
different mathematical structures you
can use categories to model logic you
can use categories to model lambda
calculus the theory of programming
languages do to church and for that
reason all three of these things
correspond so it's not just two things
that correspond but three so I want to
show you my favorite bits of that third
thing I'm going to show you two of the
coolest things I know and along the way
we will look at all the fundamental data
structures that you need for programming
so here's a category it's got some stuff
in it stuff okay so there's some stuff
in blue and then there's some arrows
between them and the arrows are labeled
with stuff in red any questions okay and
then the stuff has names so the blue
thingies are called objects not to be
confused with object-oriented
programming right object-oriented
programming is really well named you
should just object
and then the red thingies are called
arrows right and you see this all the
time right
these might this might be a type of an
argument to a function and the type of
the result and then f is a function
whose type is it takes an A and return
to be and then you can compose that with
another function G that takes a B and
return to C now the guys that came up
with category theory they weren't
interest in that they were interested in
things like a is a set and B as a set
and F is drawn from the functions from A
to B and again you can compose functions
there or even a it's some kind of
algebra and B is a different algebra
these might be different kinds of groups
or pick your favorite algebra if you
have one if you don't go out and get one
mono is good so a is a monoid and B is
Ahmad and F is a mono a morphism which
just means a function that preserves the
modern structure and then you can
compose my like morphisms to get my more
presence they just don't there are lots
of things where you've got types for the
things and functions that convert
between the things and what does that
mean well it just means two things
basically right you always have an
identity function something that takes
something into itself without changing
it and then you've got what I was just
talking about which is composition you
can first do an F and then do a G and
turns out with that very little bit of
structure it turns out you can specify
an enormous amount yes you're all silent
you're all going ooh really
that looks very trivial how can you get
anything interesting out of something so
trivial but you can it's amazing so the
first thing we're gonna oh right and
this is the same thing I just told you
written out is equation so oh well these
actually say something else right this
says if you do the identity and then you
do F it's the same as just doing F and
this says if you do F and G and you
combine them and then you take that
gives you a bigger arrow like this would
go from A to C and say H goes from C to
D then you go from A
to B to C to D there are two ways of
doing it right you can do combine f and
G and then compose with H or you can
propose F with G composed with H it
doesn't matter that's it that's the only
thing that they've assumed and by the
way I mentioned this big word ma node
before
that's all ma know it means is that
you've got an identity and you've got
some operation that's associative so I'm
now going to show you the two most
important structures in programming
languages which are also the two most
important connectives in logic what is
your favorite logical connective you yes
you have one you don't have one okay who
has a favorite logical connective good
and it is map okay I had in mind things
like conjunction and disjunction
that's okay yet that's that's very
important too it's just I wasn't clear
my apologies yes what's your favorite or
write disjunction we will get that to
that one in a minute
does anybody have a different favorite
yes and conjunction let's start with
that one okay so we've got products so
product is another name for logical
conjunction that's also another name for
something that most of you are familiar
with the record type or in particular
the pair type is what we're going to
look at but generalizes for arbitrary
records how many people have bumped into
records before right so here's all we do
we draw this fancy diagram so let's go
back okay so what does this set know go
back long button not used to this okay
we'll just leave that there right so
this says we've got an object C and an
object a and an object B and says for
every object a and for every object B
there's another object called a times B
the product of a and B and then what
does this diagram tell us it says
something else if so this is fixed for
all what once I give you a and B I've
got a times B and since there's some
arrows here there's an arrow called
first that goes from a times B to a and
an arrow called second that goes from a
times B to B and that says one more
thing which is let's say there's an
arrow seat from an arrow F from C to a
and an arrow G from C to B then there
will be an arrow which is written with
these funny angle brackets FG that goes
from C to a times B and furthermore if
you go there two different ways now
getting from C to a right you can go
straight with F or you can go the long
way around first do F G to get to a
times B and then do first to get to a
and says if you do this composition it's
the same as just doing F so since the
two different ways of getting there it
doesn't matter how you get there it's
the same function okay or in logic these
would be implications so this would be f
is a proof that from C you can derive a
and so on and then in logic it turns out
this says it from C you can prove a and
from C you can prove B then from C
there's a proof which has this name of a
and B so both a is true and B is true
and in computing what is this telling us
well a is a type of some data structure
like integers and B is the type of some
other data structure like strings and
then this would be what a record with
two fields one field called first and
one field called second and the first
field contains an integer and the second
field contains a string and this is oh
I've got some way of getting an integer
from a C but I've also got a different
way of getting a string from a C well if
I just apply those to plunk them
together I can build a pair consisting
of an integer and a string
and you might now I've realized if I
just described to you the way that you
prove a and B from C given a that C
prove a and C proves B it's the same
process okay and why do we call it the
product wait that's a good place to stop
are there any questions no questions
this is bad you guys have to ask
questions no questions on slide again
I'll try to check flight Oh occasionally
in case somebody doesn't want to raise
their hand okay so we've got products
why are they called products well right
here's the thing so if we've got three
different items of type a and two
different items of type B so 0 & 1 are
my two items of type 2 and a B and C are
my three items of type 3 then how many
different things have typed three times
two the product of three and two are
there well there's an a0 pair and an a1
pair and a b0 pair to be one parent of C
0 pair and to see when people look at 6
6 is 3 times 2 and you can see that in
general right if there was some number
arbitrary number here of things in the
first type and some arbitrary number
here of things in the second type that
you were just to get the number of
things in the product type you just
multiply the sizes of the two types it's
that clear to everybody please nod your
head if it's clear very good
lots of heads nodding please raise your
hand if you have a question yeah uh-huh
can I give you an informal definition of
what I mean by function composition oh
this is a place where I'm way to write I
just think lying one function to the
result of the other function good okay
thank you
very good question excellent any other
very good questions
not yet okay so products straightforward
let's see what else can we do with these
oh yeah and notice what we've learned
here what we've learned is given what is
this telling you so I've got we're going
to introduce one more scary notation and
it is really scary I get scared of it
too because this one doesn't just
involve italics it involves curly
letters okay and so the this gary
notation we write curly C from nice
friendly blue sea to nice friendly eight
times B this just means the set of all
possible arrows from C to a times B so
it'd be the set of all functions to take
an argument of some type C and return an
a B pair as their result and what this
equation is telling us is which
functions are there well it turns out
this is telling us the only way to get a
function from C to a times B is by
having a pair of functions one from C to
aid that gives you the first field and
one from C to B which gives you the
second field so that's it it says how
many functions are there what functions
are there from C to a times B says every
function you just build it in this way
there'll be a function from C to a and a
function from C to B and that gives you
by this construct a function from a
times B so I didn't write out the other
little bit but there's another little
bit of category theory that says not
only is this the way you get them but
this is all of them which is quite nice
so it not only says each of these gives
rise to one of these but says if you
have one of these it gives rise to these
in fact you can see that right because
we just decomposed it if we had one of
these we would get this one by composing
with first and this one by composing
this function with second so there are
one to one correspondence okay if you
have one of each you've got one of these
and vice versa so that's the nice way of
summarizing what this categorical
diagram is telling you question yes
great
Oh what is this funny thing that's we
call that scary equal or isomorphism
it's another way of saying they're the
same thing
and that isomorphism literally means if
this is a set and this is a set their
functions both ways that are inverses if
you know what about that sort of thing
okay let's do that in Java right that's
what you should always do after you
learn an idea is coded up in Java right
so products are exactly as we expect the
product of a and B has two fields first
and second one of type am of type D and
then we'll define a constructor and
we've got operations get first so plot
get the get first method is just like
applying the function first or the arrow
first I showed you before and get second
is just like the arrow second is this
clear to everybody good and then we can
actually test it out so we can build an
integer string pair which would be the
product of 1 and 2 and if we do get
first of that that will return the
number 1 and this will be down to the
string 2 or instead of implementing it
in Java we could implement it in Haskell
it's slightly simpler I can use a bigger
font so this is actually an idea of
Records that's built in to Haskell so we
just say we've got a pair type that's
got field first which is type a into
field second it's even more built-in
there's a special notation for this in
Haskell but I won't go into that so but
products the notion of product is just
built into Haskell it's easy to build
any kind of product you want so you can
see write in Java or in Haskell instead
of having our field called first and
second we get any number of fields with
any names we want and that's the general
idea of a record ok
oh and that builds one gets the
components out as before okay that's one
data type the product and then there's
this other data type the sum now sums
might be a bit less familiar to you how
many people have seen sums in functional
languages quite a few of you ok
how many people have seen variant
records in Pascal not too old okay not
many of you have seen that does anybody
else know of a favorite some type that
they've got earrings and rust - that's
not general some but that's a specific
case of a some yes union types yes union
types are very close to sums it depends
on how you do them but you have a
disjoint union that is exactly a some
very good example sorry
a sealed class in Kotlin okay I'm not
familiar with calling you'll have to
tell me about that one later but for
those of you who know Kotlin another
great example a sealed class in Kotlin
is a sum yep in the back sorry the
option type right in languages like
Haskell you've got the maybe type in ml
or Oh camel you've got the option type
that's a specific instance of a sum
that's adding one to something yes good
example okay so sums crop up everywhere
so let's look at them we've got another
nice diagram for the me it may look
slightly familiar right but this is
actually somewhat different so this
whoops I didn't mean to do that go away
go away go away right
so this says again I've gotten a I've
got to be and now I form a plus B not a
times B and I've got arrows in rather
than out which I now call left and right
and this says if I've got an arrow from
A to C remember before it was C to a and
an arrow from B to C I call these F and
G then there's a unique arrow from a
plus B to C and we write with different
shaped brackets so again it's just
saying given an arrow from A to C and an
arrow from B to C I get an error from a
plus B to C and again these commute so
if I go here and here it's the same as
just going straight right if that's what
category theory is really about avoiding
traffic jams
and if I go from B to a plus B and down
again
it's the same as going straight and
that's just what these two equations are
telling us and again this is logic right
so this is our other favorite logical
connective the disjunction or logical or
so this is saying what does it mean to
have a proof that a plus B is true and
says well either you have a proof either
you know that a plus B is true because
there's some a that you have a proof of
or you know it's true because you've got
some be that there's a proof of so I
compose my proof of a with left I get
proof of A or B I compose my proof of B
with the proof of right I get a proof of
arrow B and then what can you do
once you've proved a or b it's as well
if you know that a implies C and you
know that B implies C then you know that
a or B implies C yeah everybody's trying
to remember their logic wait is that
true
I know a implies B C and I know B
implies C and now I know either a is
true or B R true wolf a is true I know a
implies C so C is true and if B is true
then I know B implies C so C is true so
boy this is hard oh yeah if I know a or
B then I can conclude C so this is
standard logic you actually find that
definition of or in Jensen's paper that
I refer to right and then what is this
as the data structure so the data
structure it says I'm either a value of
type a so this might be integer so now
I've got something that's either an
integer or a string before we had
something that was both a pair it's an
integer and it's a string you know this
is one or the other so either it's an
integer built with left or it's a string
built with right and then what does this
do well it says given a function that
given an integer gives about type C this
takes a string to
see then how can I get from integer or
string to type C well I look at it I say
wait let's look at this thing in my hand
it's that an integer ah it's an integer
okay
so I'll use F wait nope I was wrong it's
a string so then I use G and those are
the only two cases right because it's
either an integer or a string so that's
the sum type how many people have seen
that kind of thing in a programming
language right lots of people so why is
it called a sum well again if I've got
type of three things in it a B and C or
type with two things at zero and one
it's either left a left B left C or it's
right zero or right one so there are
total of five things and you can see
that in general the number of things on
left and the number of things on the
right you add them together to get the
total number of things is that clear
yeah
oh right so you often have disjunction
right and could be both of them but no
we're saying that this is one or the
other so it's what's called a disjoint
union so even if this was looks yeah go
back there we go
if this was integer and this was integer
this would actually not be integer D
integer plus integer and you get to
twice as many integers because it could
be a left integer or a right integer
excellent question thank you okay
so and then the other thing we've
learned of course right what is this
telling us it's saying if you look at
all the arrows from a plus B to C the
only way of getting those is you have
one from A to C and one from B to C very
similar reasoning to what we had before
sorry oh what a good question thank you
look it's a x here not a plus is that a
typo no it's not a typo because to get
an arrow from a plus B to C you need
both an arrow from A to C and an arrow
from B to C so it's not a plus it's
actually at times very good question
excellent thank you is the arrow from a
plus B to C a fold
yeah the way full to rise is a similar
structure construction where you're
building lists rather than building some
for products also a good question for
those of you who know about folds so
yeah this is the secret origin of fold
yep
what does the square bracket notation
mean so it's just a case expression
right it's just saying very good
question right just the case expression
it says F is its function from A to C B
is a function G is a function from B to
C so I've got function from a
Plus b2c what does it do it's a case
expression look at the thingy is it an a
is it built with left if so use F is it
is it a be built with right if so use G
does that make sense
person ask the question say yes or no
yes good so would you like to see it in
Java
too bad you're going to see it in Java
anyway right so here it is done in Java
I had to make the print smaller right
it's not that easy in Java so we've got
some type of some interface so we've
gotten the interface some over a and B
and it has one method case expression in
case expression takes either a function
from A to C called F or function from B
to C called G and then we've got two
subclasses of that implement this
interface the left one and the right one
the left one has a private field of type
a no field of type B the right one has a
private field of type B no field of type
a and then we instantiate right we
overload this method in so that in the
left class it returns F dot apply to our
value X of type a but on the other one
it does G dot apply to our value of type
B ok so it's a case expression it looks
at which one you've got and it chooses
one so this is how you do case
expression in a object-oriented language
which makes it quite long-winded to do
something that should be really as
simple as building a pair
then we could actually use this to do
something so let's make a sum of a
string and an integer and I'll use the
string as an error message so a left
thingy is an error message and the right
thing is a number and I want to be able
to add two errants so I look at it and
so I look at the vist our Gyu mat and
it's one of two possibilities right
either it will be on the left meaning
it's an error so if it's an error I just
reached return an error in again I need
to return a sum so I'll put it on the
left so ease a string which is my error
message I checked it on the left to get
an error it I returned that errand or
it's a number M which case I look at the
other argument that and that'll also be
an errand so again it's either an error
message in which case I return an error
message or a number in which case I will
add the two numbers I've got and put
them on the right and then you can see
here that if air is error the string
error and one is the number one I add
them together to get tests tests will
again be equal to in this case error
it'll be an error message saying
something went wrong if I took one in
one and added them I get two on the
right and so on is that clear enough
okay if it's not clear I don't mind it's
because it's Java so here it is in
Haskell we get to use even bigger print
right so Haskell has this notion of some
type built into it and in fact what's
actually built into Haskell is a sum of
product types so each of these things
can be a product in the way I showed you
before so that's the basic data type in
Haskell it's just a sum of products so
the sum type is very easy to do in
Haskell and again now in much larger
print we can write the same thing I
wrote before which is this function add
which takes two errants and returns an
arrant and if we've got an error for the
first one then we return that error
we've got an error for the second one we
return that error and if they're both on
the right we just add them up and put it
back on the right and this behaves the
same way as the piece
one how many people followed that one
fantastic good you're all excellent
Haskell programmers how are we doing for
time there's but ah they turned the
clock on finally good I kept looking at
Sat 4044 dad said Wow
it's as if time is not moving question
yes or would int and list event be the
same type or two different types they're
different right list of integers has
lots more things in it because it not
only has one and two and three it also
has two lists one two three four five
six
okay one more thing Exponential's so
we've already seen these these are just
arrows right functions but how many
functions are there from a type with two
things to a type with three things well
let's see zero can be a and one can be a
or zero can be B and one can be a or 0
can be C and one can be a or zero can be
a and one can be B and so on if you're
getting bored right you all use
computers you understand what's going on
here alright so the number of functions
from 3 to 3 is just 3 squared or 9 and
in general right if this has some size
and this has some other size you just
take the second thing and raise it to
the power of the number of things and
the first thing and that's how may find
out we got so that's a reason for
calling finite maps or functions
category theorists like to confuse us by
instead saying they're Exponential's ok
there are actually now out on the
blockchain programming languages that
use this so there's one defined by a
rival of AI ohk whoops don't want to do
that by rival of AI ohk called
simplicity and I'm not going to go
through this but you can see it's got
products and it's got tights and it's
actually formula
way very similar to category theory
because each of these things is really
an arrow with just one argument so
everything is done as an arrow and
you've literally got take and drop or
their names for first and second and
Angela and Indra are their names for
left and right with the yeah a ninja
standing for left and the rough-in indra
standing for right so it's really
exactly what I showed you so it's very
cool that they've got this very
primitive simple language for
programming blockchains based on
category theory and it's got a semantics
which I'll skip over and then there's
another language called mickelson which
is a bit weird
because like they write everything all
in caps didn't we give that up in 1950s
with Fortran but they're using lots of
basic modern ideas from category theory
including Union so they call them unions
but they just mean sums and indeed they
call left and right left and right
that's cool and then they've got things
to inspect a value so instead of having
case expressions they've got if left and
if right but then you could build them
up with other things to do the proper
operation case expressions for sums at
i/o HK we've got our own language called
Plutus it's not based on category theory
I'm sorry to disappoint you it is based
on lambda calculus in particular we use
a variant of lambda calculus called
system F Omega which sounds very scary
I'll tell you a secret about system F
Omega it is very scary
I knew system F I thought okay I
understand that that's just polymorphism
and then Gerard starts writing about
system fo make I'm going Omega ooh
that's sound too infinitely worse but it
you can do things it's very cool so
system F just means polymorphism for
those of you that know languages with
type variables like Haskell or Oh camel
or these days right I showed you
generics in Java that's the same thing
that's all the F is doing it's the
mathematical theory of what it means to
have a type variable and then Omega
means it's the mathematical theory of
what it means have constructors on types
like the list type somebody asked about
the list type before so for every given
type you get a new type it goes to list
event string goes to list of string and
so on and therefore list is itself a
function from one type to another type
and that's all the Omega and F Omega is
telling you that you can do so this is
the only time I ever know I know of
maybe somebody in the audience can tell
me another one we're a commercial
company is taking a theoretical
construct and just implementing it
directly and using it in commercial
practice this will be our language for
writing smart contracts okay what have
we learned now you get to see the two
coolest things I know literally these
these are my favorite things apart from
the query Howard isomorphism itself so
you noticed those two diagrams looked
very similar right and in fact you can
get one from the other two so here I've
got by turning things upside down but
the real way to think about you just
turn every arrow backwards right so I've
turned upside down so that the arrows
always move down but here we have an
arrow from a times B to a right this
just says if you know and B then you
also know a or if you have a record with
an a field and a B field you can extract
a value of type a from it and then this
is for sums it goes the other way around
it goes from a into a plus B you can see
everything's been turned around so here
we went from out from C to a here we go
from A in
to see here we go out from C in to a
times B here we go from A plus B into C
so we've just turned all the arrows
around so these two concepts that seem
very different actually have an
identical description all you need to do
is flip the arrows which yes that's
doing nothing so there what's our
formerly called duals it's a dual
because if you flip the arrows twice you
get back where you started and right we
all learn de Morgan's law that says or
is dual - and this is the same thing
writ large in category theory but now
with lots of structure not just for
billions and you can actually use this
you could say I've compiled I know how
to compile products but from that I can
derive how to compile sums and there are
actually some advanced compilers for oh
camel that do exactly that yep right why
does this one have angle brackets and
this one have square brackets because if
you remember right you'd have to go back
but that's just so I did that and it
right there different things right so
this just says a thing he built from F
and G its name is the angle bracket
thingy and this is just a thing he also
built from F and G but it's built a
different way right this takes an arrow
from C to a and an arrow from C to B and
gives you an arrow from C to a times B
but this is different
this kid takes an hour from A to C and
an arrow from B to C and gives you an
error from a plus B to C and so it just
has this name so it's just different
ways of writing names for different
things both of which are built from F
and G did that help great
yep our C and C the same yes in that in
fact when we did this remember I said
you can fix a and fix B and this still
works for any C so you can pick any a
you want and any B you want and then
you've gotten a times B and then later
on you can go and pick a C and then this
works and this is the same thing you can
pick an A Piketty you get an A plus B
and later you can pick any C does that
help yep
I will show you the one RFP again this
you can pick any function you want going
from C to a here you can pick any
function you want going from A to C but
they're not the same right this is a
function from C to a this is a function
from A to C those are different but you
can pick any one you want good question
thank you I'm going to skip your
question because I've got one minute I
want show you the one other really cool
thing I know which is you learned all
this back in high school right because
what were those two equations this is
what does it mean to have a right it's
all the arrows from C to a times B are
the same that you've got one from C to a
and one from C to B what are all the
arrows from a plus B to C well it means
you've got one from A to C and you've
got one from B to C but you know this
equation you learned it in high school
remember I told you functions are
Exponential's so we will just take this
and rewrite it right how many things are
there here well the number of things
here is the same as a times B raised to
the C power this is the number of things
here would be C raised to the a plus B
power so just write it that way does
that look familiar to some of you okay
if high school failed you you didn't get
this much math it's easy to go back and
learn this bet you can just learn
category theory first and that follows
from that
[Applause]
if you want to learn more here's some
further reading the slides will be
online they're already on my website and
if you want to learn more about stuff
like lambda calculus I'm very pleased
I've just finished writing a textbook
called programming language foundations
in Agda that's the URL for it and you
can go there we'll explain all of lambda
calculus to you know category theory but
all of lambda calculus and all of
dependently type programming in AB de ok
so I'm going to stop there and just
leave you with one final thought which
is I don't want you to all remember that
when you do have a tough job to do but
you saw how painful it was in Java you
saw how easy it was in Haskell when
you've got a painful job to do what you
should think is this is a job
[Applause]